these men form the elite on the
ukrainian side members of the marine
corps south of the city of cerro donetsk
they're always armed always ready rifles
kept within reach and they told us they
don't have the time to be afraid
what goes through your mind when you get
the command
excitement fear
the russians have focused their
firepower in the east as they attempt to
batter their way into the donbass
territory is seized by destroying it
first
thousands have been caught in the
crossfire
the ukrainians are mounting a determined
defense
but it comes at a price
this is marine company commander
alexander waiting for the order to head
to the front what's it like when you are
sitting here in this village
waiting um
um
here's part of the training
his unit ready for battle in 10 minutes
or less
but they might not make it back
how many men have you lost since the war
began
to contract
you can't sustain those sort of losses
indefinitely can you
[Music]
he says the russians have also suffered
and he took us to a field where his
forces repulsed an enemy column back in
april
we saw shards of metal and a pair of
boots
and shallow graves where russian
soldiers have been buried
certainly dead bodies here
you can smell them
analysts make estimates about the number
of dead but the reality lies in fields
like these how many bodies do you think
are lying around in these fields
no
[Music]
the fight for life is waged in here
the back of an ad hoc ambulance
combat medics like irina zebuk deal with
broken bodies and gaping wounds
and after four months of fighting she's
tired i'm really exhausted
and
i just feel i need to
sleep like for a few weeks
to sleep watching netflix
eating like uh food from
fast food delivery yeah and
hug my mom
she says many of the country's best
soldiers have already been lost she now
treats their less experienced
replacements i see the guys that come
here they are not professional they
don't don't know what to do and they are
really very scared so that's why i'm
caring
that worries you does it yeah yeah
the invasion has done damage that will
last for generations
but these battlefield medics say they
all support the war
what choice do we have if we choose to
be ukrainian
john sparks sky news in the donbass